the Internet has changed the game in so
many ways I mean first of all now you
have the opportunity to hear a lot of
world music there is that just wasn't
possible before you would hear whatever
your radio station in your local station
wanted to play on on the radio and when
we first broke through with going up
years ago we had to convince a lot of
people to just try the song because they
thought that their audience was not
going to get it and on the contrary the
places where the song they thought
wouldn't work at all is where it worked
big I think you're going to create stars
on their own if you're an artist you
have a venue now to be able to reach
people sure you have to find your way
through it because its massive but you
have an opportunity I also think it's
much more fragmentation going on you'll
get you'll get hurt but you're going to
get her bike fewer people I think that's
just the nature of the beast we've got
so many opportunities with so many
different entertainment modes that it's
just going to get smaller but it does
give more freedom to the artist to
himself before very few got to the top
now a lot more may get there but the top
is going to be a little different than
it's been for many many decades